Hey
listen on you I'm BL on you yeah I just
want to drink you up pour you in a
silver cup you know I like to party but
you know I love your body so many things
I shouldn't do I hate myself for Hing
you yeah honestly I'm ready CU I'm sorry
if I'm selfish every time you get too
close I run the on the way and every
time you say the on I don't know what to
say back to the beginning so I can
change I do I do I do I blame it on your
love every time I [__] it up I blame it
on your love I do I blame it on your
love I can't help it I can't stop i b it
on you love I
do blame it on
your
I it sorry I'm a little scared but no
one never really carh I took you for
granted yeah did just a big
misunderstanding I just want to spend
the night all night sleeping in your
Bight yeah go watch a little
TV I love it when you need me every time
you get too close run run away every
time you say the on I don't know what to
say back back to the beginning so I
could change I do I I do I do I blame it
on your love every time I [__] it up it
I blame it on your love I do I blame it
on your love I going help it I going
stop I'm blame it
on I
[Music]
do blame it on you
bling on
you I don't know what's wrong with this
girl Charlie she crazy blame it on the
blame it on the blame it on the juice
looking at my booty like you don't know
what to do baby I know that you can't
control it but my body like a switcher
just roll it I'mma give you one chance
to fall in love give you one chance
don't [__] this
up I'm trying to catch Millions I ain't
trying to catch
feelings I blame it on your love every
time I [__] it up [__] it up I'll blame
it on
you I do I blame it on your love I going
help it I going I blame it on your love
I do I blame it on your love every time
I [__] it up I blame it on your love I
do I blame it on you Your Love help I'm
St I'll B it on
you I do okay that's
it hey friends I hope you enjoyed that
taste of flow uh real quickly if you are
interested in grabbing a set of those or
poy Pro LED contact poy that I was using
in this video you can do so by using the
promo code drexfactor with a zero
instead of an O at checkout over at
Ultra po.com that'll give you 5% off of
your order and it helps out the channel
so everybody wins thank you to ultra for
sponsoring this video and giving me an
excuse to get out and flow every month
speaking of thank yous I owe some thank
yous to the Friends of the channel big
thanks too dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Tera light toys spinballs and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- buus friend of the
channel That is Becca Becken thank you
so very much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission also this video
and the videos on the this channel would
not be possible without my supporters on
patreon in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now if you like
the content that I produce and you'd
like to see more of it there's an easy
way to make that happen and that's to
head on over to patreon at patreon.com
drexfactor Po and sign up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
pois spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you if you'd like check out
more of these flow sessions I will
include a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen if you're watching on
YouTube thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today
yourselves and I'll see you with a new
video real soon take care now peace